what is the European Parliament it's the
only EU body directly elected by the
people
every five years voters choose over 700
members or MEPS to represent nearly 450
million Europeans
MEPS work on your behalf debating
shaping and passing laws on issues
Central to our daily lives
Parliament defense Freedom equality and
the rule of law across the EU and
promotes democracy and human rights
around the world
intellect the president of the European
commission and makes sure EU
institutions are doing their job
properly
MEPS decide how the eu's money is spent
and sign off on the EU budget the
European Parliament is your link to the
decisions that matter